[Musique]
le yukon est un endroit dangereux
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
je suis monté ici parce que je ne
voulais plus côtoyé personnes et puis
j'ai rencontré bac je ne sais pas d'où
tu viens
je sais où tu aujourd'hui bienvenue au
bout du bout du monde on va lui laisser
une minute je crois qu'il n'a encore
jamais vu de neige d'un film avec
beaucoup d'émotion de voir harrison ford
dans un rôle où il nous parle de
beaucoup d'émotion c'était bien c'était
émouvant
c'était émouvant même les petites qui se
sont mis à pleurer c'est serrar est
vraiment magique
le voir justement parler d'amour par
rapport aux animaux de ne pas faire du
mal c'est c'est un autre registre et
c'est pareil rare de le voir avec ses ce
type de rôle les images le son le
personnage la forêt en plus c'était
super c'est plutôt à vue pour les
enfants mais les grands sont émerveillés
aussi et tout laventure du début jusqu'à
la fin et magnifique île aventure
humaine et l aventure animal quoi
exceptionnel mon mari sur une ford
donc voilà exceptionnel et vraiment je
trouvais fallait alors beaucoup touché
c'est très ému
[Musique]
jupe au top cette lettre je n'ai jamais
de croire en quoi que ce soit autant
qu'il croit en toi